the green knight is a fresh take on the
classic hero's journey
like with so many heroic odysseys the
green knight does many things but above
all else it is this
extremely and incontrovertibly weird
there are magic spells
ghosts giants spiritual foxes and
nightmarish fates
what in this supernatural world is real
and what is the imagining of our hero
circle wayne
the answer to that isn't immediately or
easily illuminated
similarly even the way the story ends
seems almost shrouded in mystery
not to worry though we can work the
strands of this strange tapestry
together until they weave a pattern that
at least makes some semblance of sense
the green knight is the tale of a young
man named gawain who just so happens to
be the son of morgan lafaye
and thus the nephew of king arthur and
queen guinevere the green knight never
uses these names other than gawain's but
as the tale is based on the 14th century
romantic epic sir gawain and the green
knights we can make some inferences
at the start of our tale gwen played by
deb patel leads a free uneventful life
full of wine women in song he seems to
spend more nights in the bed of one
woman in particular the vessel
played by elysia vikander who dreams of
being his lady in the courtly royal
sense
but it's not until christmas day that
the dye is cast
king arthur invites gawain to sit with
him in gwenevere while they discuss
the possibility that gawain might
someday have nightly tales to tell
dwayne's mother summons the titular
green knight who challenges all nights
in the hall to cut him with his own axe
and
in exchange have the same wound visited
upon them by the green knight in a
year's time
i will meet him you understand this
challenge
i did gwen accepts the challenge and
thinking he solved the situation chops
the green knight's head clean off
but the green knights is no mere mortal
so he picks up his own head and rides
away
laughing all the way and the knowledge
that he will kill gawain in a year's
time
this moment is so important because it
tells us what this incarnation of gwen
is all about
there are many fictional accounts of
gwen which portray him at times as noble
and at other times as graceless callow
and
utterly dishonorable the green knight
portrays gawain as a man manipulated too
easily by his own ambition
this gwain wants to have song song of
his gallantry and he wants people to see
him as honorable however from the outset
he seems more interested in perception
and power than he does with
the actual responsibilities of
knighthood when gawain arrives one year
later at the green chapel as the green
knight demanded acts in hand
hypothetically ready to be decapitated
there exists a duality of desire within
him one which wishes to die a hero and
another which wishes to live and become
king the end of the green nights is
about understanding the consequences of
both choices
the end of the green knight is split
into two sections what could happen
and what does happen in each gwain has
in his possession a magic belt that is
meant to protect him from any blow
and yet at first we see gawain distrust
his own magic and flee
reflecting the cowardice we see in him
throughout the story during his quest
wayne is defeated by three lowly thieves
we watch him accidentally drug himself
with hallucinogenic mushrooms
and we see him betray the word he gives
to a lord played by joel edgerton
as he keeps the lord's property and
gives himself over sexually to the
lord's wife who was also played by
elysia mcandrew
again and again gwen denies his own
knighthood when that title would get him
into trouble
and yet when gwen returns home after
running away and forsaking his word to
the green knight as well
he still accepts knighthood from arthur
as though he deserves it not only that
but gawain also takes a son he has with
essel leaving her forsaken
marries into royal blood and becomes
king a terrible king
dwayne's subjects despise him and while
his magic belt protects him he watches
his son die in his kingdom fall to ruin
in the end gwen dies a failure to his
name and his people with neither honor
nor nobility
and then suddenly we're back in the
green chapel as though nothing ever
happened
wayne's future a mere glimpse of things
to come in the face of that horrifying
destiny gwen removes his protective belt
and allows the green knight to lop off
his head
we get one earlier glimpse of this side
of wayne when he helps the ghost of
winifred find her own head at the bottom
of the lake
in that moment gawain helps winifred
find peace in the end the green knight
is about how it's better for gwayne to
die an honorable person than to live a
long miserable life
a stranger to oneself and a victim of
one's own most craven nature
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you